c'est bien une visite pastorale qui a
effectué à ars pape jean paul ii au
coeur même de la commune au milieu des
fidèles rassemblés près de lui
les habitants d'ars des plus anciens
nouveaux nés comme brennan que jean paul
ii a tenu un instant dans ses bras il a
donné au pape il a pris dans les bras il
a béni et puis j'avais latin sur les
rails l'an passé la victoire en huit ans
j'avais pu le temps de faire une photo
non jamais
le souverain pontife était ici en
pèlerinage recueilli silencieux pour
saluer la mémoire du saint curé d'ars
l'exemple d'un ministère sacerdotal pour
évoquer un peu plus tard le portrait
robot du prêtre de l'an 2000
mais là au milieu des habitants d'ars le
temps était plutôt au recueillement et à
l'émotion pour certains
et puis familiale j'espérais le voir de
plus près quand même parce qu'ailleurs
on aime croire qu'ils voulaient d'abord
mirare ces clauses restent pendant que
les nombreux journalistes présents dans
la commune bénéficié d'une pause dans le
programme marathon du saint père celui
ci se rendait sous un chapiteau face à
l'église
la six mille prêtres diacres
séminaristes et leurs familles il
accueillait une nouvelle fois le pape
rappeler à tous les exigences du
sacerdoce convertir guérir sauver jal
frère beaucoup de nos contemporaines
semble devenu indifférent au salut de
l'homme nous jouissions nous achète par
deux fois ou bien nous résignons nous au
cours de la messe l'après-midi
concélébrée dans une prairie à la sortie
du village s'est une nouvelle fois cette
idée du rôle des prêtres dans la société
que le pape devait rappeler que référent
souvent au curé d'ars ouvriers insolite
de la moisson qui s'opère pour le salut
des hommes selon jean paul ii il devait
aussi insisté sur l'importance des
ordinations sacerdotales d'avoir une
charité qu'ils déguerpissent d'obtenir
avec loi